This video is brought to you by Skillshare and online learning community for
creators, with thousands of classes in design business,
and more Skillshare is giving away a free trial of premium membership.
If you click the link in the description below,
that's what the first thousand people only more on them. And just a bit
When one thinks of the first world war two, that just comes to mind.
The war on the grounds was a bloody stalemate with modern weapons,
but our data tactics that led to millions of soldiers being slaughtered by
contrast the war in the air is still heavily romanticized.
Over a hundred years later,
barely a decade after the Wright brothers first demonstrated a functional
airplane.
The combatants of the first world war had developed a number of aircraft for
military purposes, most famous of all of course, but the fighter planes,
the rumbling loud devices built out of woods with canvas wings and an open
cockpit may seem ridiculous by modern standards, but during the war,
they were at the cutting edge of technology.
Fighter pilots were celebrated heroes, the lost nights of Europe,
who jousted at each other with machine guns in the name of Ana,
no one typified this image better than Manfred Von Richt.
Often with 80 confirmed area victories retro often was the leading ACE of the
first world war. More than that, it was a national celebrity in Germany.
The public followed his exploits in newspapers and infantry soldiers carried
pictures of him in their pockets.
Rickshaw often followed his own code of chivalry.
That ends in the respect of both his fellow pilots and his enemies who
nevertheless learned to fear the appearance of his brightly colored red airplane
in the sky is the red Baron XE as commonly known has become a cultural
touchstone easily,
the most famous German soldier of the first world war and is one of the most
celebrated fighter pilots of all time.
[Inaudible].
Fred Vaughn wrecked off and was born on the 2nd of May,
1892 near breasts law in lower say leisure, which is today part of Poland.
He was part of a prominence Prussian aristocratic family or young gap.
He has the Nobel titer fry ha which translates into Baron in English like many
children of his social class.
Richthofen was well-educated and excelled at outdoor pursuits,
such as horseback riding and hunting.
He was also well-regarded as a gymnast in school,
particularly on the parallel bars where he was noted for his fast reflexes young
mantra. It was destined for military service from a young age, beginning,
his cadet training in 1904 at the age of 11, when he graduated in 1911,
he received a commission into a cavalry regiments and appropriate posting for
someone of his position,
but he didn't have time to settle into peacetime military life for long.
[Inaudible].
For hundreds of years,
the major powers of Europe sought to maintain a balance of power with each
other. After the defeat of Napoleon in 1815,
this was achieved by an almost constantly shifting series of alliances between
the principle countries of Europe, with a few exceptions,
this complicated system work to maintain peace throughout the continents over
the course of the following hundred, but the Apple cart was upset in 1871.
When Prussia joined together with many of the surrounding German speaking
provinces to form the German empire with the former King of Prussia.
Now the German emperor Kaiser,
the new state sought to assert itself as a major player in world affairs,
building a substantial military force and just pushing a colonial empire in
Africa and East Asia,
this alarms France and great Britain who formed an Alliance with each other and
with the Russian empire to defend against German aggression,
Germany in turn allied itself with its Southern neighbor,
the Austro-Hungarian empire,
the balance of power was maintained in this way at the start of the 20th
century,
but it meant that any regional conflict involving any of the major powers would
quickly escalate into a continent spanning war.
That was exactly what happened in the summer of 1914 when the Austro-Hungarian
embar blamed Serbia for the assassination of the air to the Austrian throne and
declared war Serbia was allied with Russia who declared war on Austria errands
that dragged everyone else into the conflicts.
And for the first time in a hundred years, the entirety of Europe was at war.
Military technology had changed drastically in the last hundred years,
and it quickly became apparent that cavalry regiments were worse than useless
against machine guns and trench warfare, the German cover units,
all dismounted and utilized in support roles behind the front lines.
Manfred Von Rex, often chafed at the Sega to get into combat himself.
His Johns came in May, 1915.
When he received a transfer to the Imperial Gemini service,
the young Baron was going to learn how to fly airplanes.
[Inaudible].
Rick dolphin had joins the German air force at a time of great transition in
aviation history.
All of the major combatants were trying to figure out how to best employ this
new technology in the war effort.
The obvious answer was to Mount machine guns on the planes,
but the engine is still needed to overcome.
There are the glaring problem of avoiding shooting off your own propeller when
firing the gun directly forwards, the Germans figured it out first,
they invented the synchronization gear mechanism.
That's allowed the machine guns to find between the blades of the propeller.
This gave them an initial period of air superiority known as the Fokker scourge
before long purpose built fighter planes were being produced.
And the war in the air escalated as pilots started trying to shoot down each
other. In August, 1916,
Richthofen was flying to see to bomber planes on the Eastern front.
When he was visited by Oswald bulkhead,
Boca was looking for pilots to join his newly formed fighter squadron.
And he signed up rich orphan Boko was a legend in the German air force.
He was the original fighter race having shot down 40 planes.
It was also one of the first pilots to develop aerial tactics for his squadron,
developing a series of maxims known as dicta bulker that became standard
practice for all pilots in the first world war things like flying with the sun
behind you. So your enemy can't see you coming,
attacking from behind at close range and attacking in a formation.
Instead of as individual planes breaks open would take the dicta Boca to heart
very early in his fighting career and gave him credit for why he was so
successful over,
got his furnace confirmed scale on September the 17th of 1916 and had shot down
five more by October the 28th,
when Oswald Boga was killed in a mid-air collision with another Jeman plane.
By January, 1917, he had shot down 16 planes and received the Paul and Marines.
Germany's highest award for gallantry.
Also known as the blue max that same month,
he was named commander of his own squadron,
yester 11 and last embarked on the path of becoming a legend.
And if you're looking to become absolutely legendary,
you need to join today's sponsor Skillshare and online learning community for
creators, with thousands of classes in design business, and more now,
unlike some websites where you have to pay the individual classes with a premium
membership from Skillshare, you get unlimited access.
So you can take as many as you want,
which is pretty nice on someone who will just jump into a particular part of a
classic extract.
The information I need from just that little section and move on to something
else. I mean, if the rest of the class is great,
then maybe I'll see the other stuff,
but really I'm looking to solve a specific problem.
There are however classes that I've taken all the way through,
which are particularly good. I'd recommend those.
There was one on email productivity from Alexandra, Samuel.
That is well worth a look.
If your email inbox was as disastrous as mine,
there's also building good habits with Thomas Frank, another great one. Anyway,
join more than 8 million creators learning with skill shack.
The first thousand people to use the link in the description,
we'll get a free trial of Skillshare premium membership.
And it's often that it's only around $10 a month.
[Inaudible].
Soon after assuming command of yester 11 Rex often got the idea in his head to
paint his airplane bright red. No one is really sure why he did it,
but words soon spread across Europe and allied pilots grew to fear the
appearance of rich orphans,
red app line and battle as it usually meant death to his enemies,
German newspapers on the other hand,
loved the pain job and they soon began referring to him as
[inaudible] the red fighter pilots. There was the allies,
however that bestowed upon him, his most famous nickname,
the red Baron yester 11 began to rack up aircraft skills.
And Rick Trophon led the way during bloody April,
1917 ratio often shown down 22 British planes, including four in a single day.
You now had 52 aerial victories.
You assumed promoted again to command of a fighter wing of four squadrons.
The other German pilots seeking to emulate the Baron began painting their planes
in various bright colors as well.
The outgoing soon became known as rector orphans flying circus,
which often was a master of the very difficult and dangerous crafts in the first
world war as at-home.
That was a game of high-stakes maneuvers conducted at close range.
When squadrons of planes engaged each other,
they broke off into a series of one-on-one engagements.
The pilots called dogfights. The goal was to get directly behind your opponents,
also known as being in the planes,
six o'clock position and fire your machine gun at close range since the gums
were fairly. And is that farther away? You were the worst. It would go.
You did this until it damaged. The plane so much fell out the sky,
or you shot the pilot.
This was not as easy as you might sink cause these planes had an open cockpit,
meaning the pilots were exposed to wind speeds in excess of 150 kilometers per
hour. In frigid. Temperatures often compounded by wet weather.
You had to pay attention to both the instruments in the cockpit,
as well as the air space,
all around you to avoid crashing into the ground or other aircraft.
And of course you have to contend with the fact that people on both the grounds
and in other planes were shooting at you.
Rick Hoffman was not a particularly acrobatic flier leaving the complicated
maneuvers to pilots like his younger brother, Luther,
where he excelled was his skill as a tactician and a marksman.
He didn't have to out fly as enemies when he could out smart and down shoot
them.
He was also noted for his chivalrous conduct once he was sure the enemy plane
was crippled. He stopped shooting out S he avoided strafing downs.
Pilots who survived that crash landing calling himself a sportsman,
not a butcher. He insisted on entertaining,
captured allied pilots with dinner and drinks before they were sent off to
prisoner of war camps.
This was considered to be proper behavior by something that was expected from a
German nobleman.
[Inaudible].
I was seriously wounded in the hat on July the sixth, 1917,
while flying a combat mission. Those suffering from temporary partial blindness,
he was able to force his airplanes land essentially intact behind German lines
in Belgium. Before being rushed to a hospital,
doctors have to perform several surgeries to remove skull fragments from his
brain. He was able to recover enough to be back in the cockpit by July the 25th,
but the headaches and post-flight nausea,
he suffered in the aftermath was so bad that he was forced to take medical leave
for almost two months in the fall of 1917, while grounded,
rich often authored an autobiography that was heavily censored and edited by
German propagandists to paint the war and his actions in a proper
patriotic and positive light. By this time,
the German government was sanctioning a cult of hero worship based around the
leading German fighter raises in general.
And Rick's often in particular newspapers, printed stories of his exploits.
Every time he claimed to kill it was front page news, some newspapers,
even at score sheets,
tallying the kill totals of the top German pilots with Rex often by now at the
top,
soldiers in the trenches could be found carrying his picture in their pockets.
And he was swarmed by well-wishes and fans, wherever he went,
that was serious consideration to grounding in permanently,
as he was held in such high regard by the German people,
that it was fair to that his death in combat would weaken public morale,
perhaps jeopardizing the entire war effort.
But Rick Trophon wouldn't hear of it.
He argued that like a common soldier in the trenches.
He must take his chances like everyone else rich often returned to the air in
November, 1917, but he did it in the cockpit of a new airplane.
The Fokker [inaudible] was much more powerful than anything the Germans had
flown before.
And Rick Hoffman immediately recommended that the entire air force be equipped
with them as soon as possible.
It is this image that of the red painted airplane that has come to be most
associated with the rail.
In the spring of 1918,
Germany made a bid to win the war with one decisive blow in late 1917 Russia.
Now under the control of Lennon and the communists signed a peace treaty with
the central powers ending the war on the Eastern front. At the same time,
the United States of America rendered the war on the side of the allies,
general Erich Ludendorff.
Now the leading figure in most of the German war effort knew that rapidly
transferring troops from East to West and smashing the allied position on the
Western front before the Americans could arrive in force was essential in March.
They launched their spring offensive,
breaking through the allied lines and racing towards Paris.
The war in the app was considered important to this offensive.
So Retrophin often squadrons were busy and a little less than a month wrecked
off, often shot down 15 allied planes,
including several of the new British built Sopwith camels that were built
specifically to counter the air superiority that Rick Hoffman squadrons had
enjoyed in 1917 on April the 20th,
1918 during a dogfight retrofit and shutdown to camels within three minutes of
each other, scoring is 79th and 80th kills the next day, April 21st,
RET orphans,
cousin Wolfram was joining them on his first mission because he was new retrofit
audit his cousin to stay out of the fighting.
And when contact was made with the enemy,
he was to circle and watch the battle from above at 11:00 AM. Erected orphans,
planes tangled with the 209th squadron of the Royal air force commanded by
captain Roy Brown Wolfram on at react often did what his cousin had ordered and
circled above the freight. As it happens. One of the RAF pilots,
Wilfred may had been ordered by captain Brown to do the same thing as he was
also new may Saul Wolfram's plane, all by itself,
near his position and decided to attack him.
The red Baron looked top and soar his cousin under attack,
and immediately flew to his rescue at firing on Mae and forcing him to break
away from the fight raked off and continued to Jace may,
as he descended towards the grounds.
Captain Roy Brown saw what was happening and attempted to intervene,
firing a burst at Richt orphan from above before having to pull up shortly to
avoid hitting the ground.
Rich often briefly moved to avoid Brown's attacks and inexplicably turned to go
after may again,
despite the British pilots being fallen away from the battle and dangerously
close to the ground that was occupied by allied soldiers.
There are many theories as do I react often,
always the cautious and meticulous piloted behaved in this reckless way.
Some things that he would have braided his subordinates for it is believed that
the head injury that raked off and had suffered in July,
1917 had caused permanent brain damage impacting his ability to make rational
judgements about what was safe and what wasn't his target fixation amaze plane
is a possible indicator of this brain damage.
He may have also been suffering from acute combat stress and overload based on
two continuous years of Ariel combats,
watching his closest friends and comrades die in the near fatal maiming of his
brother. This could have put him in a disassociative,
perhaps even suicidal state where either he wasn't aware of the danger posed or
simply didn't cap.
It is also entirely that with the spring offensive in full motion,
Rachel didn't realize where the front lines were and didn't know he had strayed
into enemy territory,
or it could have been a combination of all of these factors.
There's really no way to know.
What we do know is that shortly after avoiding the attack by captain Brown,
Rick Tovan was fought on by soldiers on the grounds with both rifles and machine
guns.
A single bullet struck Ricks often from behind causing massive damage to his
vital organs. He was able to land his,
try playing in the field near the som river controlled by Australian troops.
Some of them rushed to his plane, but by the time they arrived,
the red Baron was dead. Two weeks shy of his 26 bucks.
Uh, uh.
Squadron of the Australian Royal flying Corps took responsibility for rich
orphans body. Most allied pilots greatly respected the barons.
The Australians honored him the next day by burying him with full military
honors that a small cemetery outside of amnion.
Many other squadrons sent wreaths,
including one that was inscribed to our gallons and worthy foe just as the
German government feared the death of man tread Von direct often was met with
widespread shock and dispatch the spring offensive fizzled out soon after his
death. And over the summer,
the allies began to regain all the territory the Germans had taken and then
collapsed their main defensive line, pushing them back toward Germany itself.
This call has rots in Berlin that forced the Kaiser to abdicate and for the
German government to Sue for peace.
The first world war ended on November the 11th, 1918.
When the armistice came into effect rich orphans,
tri plane was torn apart by souvenir hunters. In fact,
none of his planes are believed to exist in tact today.
His planes at that arrow,
a considerably more fragile than the aluminum built planes of later generations.
Captain Roy Brown was officially credited with shooting down Richthofens plane.
Although modern historical consensus is that Rick Hoffman was actually killed by
ground flop.
Wolfram Von Rick dolphins survived to the end of the war and would go on to
become a senior commands or in the German Luftwaffe during world war II,
rich dolphin's body was moved three times from its original resting place.
In the early 1920s Richter often was moved by the French to a military cemetery
and frequent. Then in 1925,
his brother Boko had the remains taken to Germany to be buried in Berlin, uh,
to military cemetery, along with many other famous German soldiers.
The cemetery was situated on the border between West and East Berlin during the
cold war and rich orphans,
gravestone suffered damage from bullets fired by Soviet gods,
trying to prevent people from crossing the Berlin wall in 1975,
the rich orphan family moved his body to a family plot in the West German city
of Wiesbaden, where it is today.
Rick softens larger than life persona persisted. Well after his death,
he is one of the most recognizable figures of the first world war and perhaps
one of the most famous fighter pilots of all time.
The name red Baron is something that most everyone has heard,
even if they don't know anything about the real life Manfred vulnerary it often
prompts the most indelible way he has been immortalized is by the comic book
strip peanuts in the comics, Snoopy often imagines.
He is flying a Sopwith camel, which is actually as doghouse and his great rival.
The red Baron continually shoots him down much to Snoopy's chagrin.
Manfred Von Richter often had an out-sized impact on aviation history.
He helps lay the foundation for future fighter pilots to follow inventing
tactics that are still taught to military pilots a hundred years later.
More than that helped forge the image of the fighter pilots into the public
consciousness in the modern mechanical horrors of war.
He was the last night he obeyed the ancient code of chivalry and treated as
enemies with respect to Donna. He may have died tragically at the age of 25,
but his actions and persona have ensured that his name and deeds will live
on forever. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do smash that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe also.
Please do check it out. Fantastic sponsors Skillshare linked to below.
Thank you for watching.